this video is made possible by morning
brew morning burrows an email newsletter
sent out every weekday morning you wake
up with the most relevant curated and
informative business news from Wall
Street to Silicon Valley delivered a
right to your inbox morning brew cuts
through the clutter of business news
providing a quick and high-quality
delivery politic for politics you'll
love what morning brew does for business
I've been subscribed for a few months
now and the short pieces that come into
my email inbox each day genuinely
interesting stuff and that's not an easy
feat but morning brew absolutely deliver
whether you want to learn about startup
news from Silicon Valley or investment
news from Wall Street morning brew have
you covered and it's quick and easy to
read with a cup of coffee in the morning
or maybe on your commute click the link
in the description below to sign up to
morning brew comm and get to the most
informative and witty business
newsletter arounds and let's get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
something is having in Israel
now I don't think it would be an
understatement to say that the State of
Israel has been in the spotlight since
it was founded in 1948 which all in
about 70 years of war with their Arab
neighbors seven decades of severe
tensions due to the Palestinian
situation seventy years of international
isolation only mitigated by the strong
support of the United States but hold on
a second because all of that is changing
in recent years Israel has gone from
being as vilified as Lindsay Lohan to
being as exalted as a Natalie Portman
and you might think I'm exaggerating but
have a look at what 2018 s number one
villain had to say about the country
Saudi prince says Israelis have right to
their own land the turnaround is so
dramatic that the Israeli national
anthem has made it to wait for it Abu
Dhabi
[Music]
see for yourself in October of 2018 at
the medal ceremony of an international
judo tournament in Abu Dhabi the Israeli
national anthem was played for the first
time ever in the United Arab Emirates
a woman you see crying emotionally is
the Israeli Minister of Culture and
sports Miri Regev the former Brigadier
General in the 2006 Lebanon War
certainly something of an about-face
isn't it this is especially true when we
take into account that to this day not
one country on the Arabian Peninsula
officially recognizes Israel as a state
but that's not the end of it around the
same time the Israeli prime minister
himself Benjamin Netanyahu made a secret
visit to the Sultan of Oman in the past
three months several Israeli ministers
have visited the Dubai Emirates and have
even met with Qatari representatives yep
we really did hear that correctly so how
on earth did Israel achieve such
diplomatic advances in such a short time
what are the Palestinians think of all
of this and perhaps the most important
question of all is an enduring peaceful
resolution finally in sight for this
region that has spent decades as the
planets powder-keg today on visual
politic we're gonna answer all of these
questions but first let's rewind for a
bit of history
[Music]
a difficult birth
may the 14th 1948 ben-gurion proclaims
the independence of the State of Israel
the very next day this brand-new nation
is invaded by the armies of five Arab
countries but why was that this rapid
and dramatic reaction well it turns out
that since the late 1800s Jews had been
buying up land in Palestine which at the
time was under the control of the
Ottoman Empire in the late 19th century
anti-semitism it was running rife in
Europe so more and more Jewish people
were emigrating to the traditional land
of their ancestors after the first world
war however Palestine was put under a
mandate leaving the running of the
country and the hands of the UK and in
that solve the problem not exactly
if the British put forward policies
favoring the Jews the Arabs reacted with
riots and protests of all kinds them on
the other hands of the British favored
the Arab interests Jewish armed groups
lapse into action
[Music]
20 years later World War one further
complicated the situation as you can
imagine the Jewish exodus to Palestine
only increased in the wake of the
horrors of the Holocaust what's more
it's highlighted the need for a
dedicated Jewish state
[Music]
meanwhile in Palestine the situation
became increasingly unstable overwhelmed
by events the British authorities handed
control over to the United Nations and
that chain of events brought about one
of the most contentious resolutions in
the history of the United Nations and
that's resolution 181 with this
resolution the UN proposed dividing
Palestine into two separate states the
first of roughly 14,000 square
kilometers would be controlled by a
hebrew governments with a jewish
population of around 60% first the
remaining 40% would be Arab the second
slightly smaller state of around 11,000
kilometers would be controlled by the
Palestinian people with a Jewish
population of barely 2% at the same time
Jerusalem Bethlehem and the holy lands
would be placed under an international
mandate the Jews accepted the resolution
the Arabs did not that's why the day
after the proclamation of Israel's
independence in 1948 the country was
invaded by Egypt Syria Lebanon Iraq and
Jordan and with that began a conflict
that's been dragged out for seven
decades
[Music]
[Applause]
Israel despite being a fledgling nation
and facing the armies of five countries
the clear Victor and this victory has
allowed Israel to expand its territory
considerably it was also the first
victory of the newly created Israel
Defense Forces which went on to become
one of the most powerful armies in the
world today but this wouldn't be the
only war between Israel and the Arab
countries far from it in 1967 the so
called six-day war took place during
which Israel took control of the Golan
Heights East Jerusalem for the West Bank
the Gaza Strip and the Sinai Peninsula
it was just six days it was such a
humiliating defeat for the Arab
countries that they started planning
their revenge
[Music]
six years later during the yom kippur
Jewish holiday Israel was attacked by
the Egyptian and Syrian army's this time
the warden lost six days but 19 and the
result was practically the same a clear
and rapid victory for the Israeli army
six people small as it is surrounded as
it is by enemies has decided to live
[Applause]
[Music]
it was possibly as a result of this war
that the Egyptian President Anwar
al-sadat made one of his most famous
statements Russians can give you arms
but only the United States can give you
a solution Anwar al-sadat Egyptian
President Sadat takes the first shot
[Music]
1978 marked a turning point Israel's
relationship with its natus the Egyptian
President Anwar Sadat traveled to
Jerusalem recognized the existence of
Israel as a state before the Hebrew
Parliament's can got ready to negotiate
a peace treaty
[Music]
boon Elijah mana see heavy hillman
Manila wanna economy could Lily its loss
and unruffled by banana be cool in and
won a man I want to live to see that day
of peace between you and up a peace
between all our neighbors and that's our
with a little mediation from Jimmy
Carter the Camp David agreements were
forged Ezreal returns the Sinai
Peninsula Egypt since Egypt became the
first arab country to have diplomatic
relations with the Jewish state let us
pledge to make the spirit of Camp David
a new chapter in the history of our
nation's Thank You mr. president
while stood out may have taken the
crucial first step he paid a very high
price for it just three years later he
was assassinated by Islamic radicals
even so Egypt stuck to the terms of the
Camp David agreements name are you
wondering now what was the outcome of
these agreements for Israel well
basically two things happens first
Jewish settlement began to emerge in the
West Bank and Gaza and this continues to
be a sticking point and one of the main
obstacles to peace between the
neighboring states secondly there was a
huge increase in violence and terrorist
attacks s Hezbollah and the Palestinian
Liberation Organization under Yasser
Arafat's leadership gathered force at
this time both organizations they were
operating out of Lebanon which led to
Israeli military intervention in that
country on two separate occasions the
arab-israeli conflicts it didn't let up
despite the conflicts Jordan also
recognized the Jewish state in the 1990s
this was during the time of the Madrid
and Oslo negotiations where progress was
made towards Palestinian self-government
up until that point
Palestine's power to make an implement
its own policies had been very limited
in practice that may explain the years
of prolonged tension and be the reason
that the conflict is yet to come to a
satisfactory resolution hemos pensado's
con frecuencia syros condiciones que un
dia hicieron possibly la convivencia
fruity fara podrían repetitious
[Music]
Cold War in a hot region to those who
regularly followed visual politics this
might not come as a surprise to you
the Middle East is experiencing its own
version the Cold War the clash between
Riyadh and Tehran has reached an
unprecedented level this cold war has
intensified since the end of 2017 when
Saudi Arabia the Arab Emirates Bahrain
and Egypt imposed an almost total
economic blockade on Qatar because of
its relations with Iran and also for its
support of the Muslim brothers by the
way this group is also very closely
linked with Hamas in Palestine Hamas in
turn maintains very close relations with
Qatar Hamas pays Gaza clerks
after receiving fifteen million dollars
from Qatar but nowadays in the Middle
East having good relations with Qatar it
will cost you dearly
Egypt court sentences mercy to 25 years
in Qatar spy case all right so no
seconds Egypt Qatar you're probably
thinking right now Simon what on earth
does any of this have to do with Israel
this makes no sense well the fact is
that this Arab cold war provides Israel
with a rather unique opportunity so
let's break it down
[Music]
Israel is a declared enemy of Iran and
vice-versa for Jerusalem the ayatollahs
government is their archenemy and now
you've got the old saying my enemy's
enemy is my friend
so that means suddenly Israel has become
a potential ally for Riyadh and a very
important ally indeed
[Music]
and there's more here the Arab countries
have want Washington support at all
costs and so here's a question what
would please the White House more than
Arab nations becoming close to the
Jewish state I mean it's just a
no-brainer for them and if we add to all
of that the fact that many Arab capitals
are getting tired of Palestine and if
Hamas is ties with Qatar and this looks
like a done deal that's why when
Australia suddenly announced that it
recognized Jerusalem as the Israeli
capital we saw reactions like this
Bahrain FM defends Australia's decision
on Jerusalem but I don't think that this
is just about geopolitics on this
occasion money is also playing a key
role so let's take a look at that
business as usual we've mentioned this
in several videos over the last two
decades Israel's economy has skyrocketed
[Music]
the country has become a world leader in
technological innovation and now to top
it all off it has discovered huge
deposits of natural gas off its coast so
now we're beginning to see headlines
like this Egyptian firm to buy fifteen
billion dollars of his really natural
gas yeah we're talking about the most
significant economic agreements ever
achieved - between these two countries
but Israel's economic ties with the Arab
world they go much further than that you
see while the Gulf countries may not
officially recognize the Israeli state
they do recognize their technological
superiority especially in the areas of
defense and security and this has
far-reaching consequences in the midst
of the Arab cold war Israeli technology
has become highly prized indeed so much
so that there are strong indications
that Israel is already supplying
technological equipment to Saudi Arabia
while the Saudi secret services are
sharing information with the Israeli
intelligence agency Mossad relations
indeed seem to be so good that according
to US sources Saudi Arabia may have
bought part of the Israeli missile
defense system technology known as the
Iron Dome now to be fair Israel has
denied this but you know in this type of
business discretion certainly rules
there is an alignment of Israel and
other countries in the Middle East that
would have been unimaginable ten years
ago certainly in my lifetime I never saw
anything like it and I'm the same age as
the State of Israel more or less so it's
an extraordinary thing Benjamin
Netanyahu
[Music]
these days visits from the highest
Israeli authorities to many Arab
countries are turning into a common
event significant trade agreements that
being signed and security and defense
ties are at unprecedented levels
so essentially Arab and Israeli
relations seem to be getting better and
better with plenty of nods and winks
between the main players one example of
this would be the Saudi government's
decision to allow commercial flights to
Israel to cross Saudi airspace for the
first time in 70 years of course though
all of this has a downside dealing with
democratic countries is not the same as
dealing with dictatorships that
sometimes seem to be stuck in the Middle
Ages you may get nasty surprises like
this one is really software helped
Saudis spy on Khashoggi lawsuit says
anyway that's how things stand today
everything points the likelihood that
the arab-israeli conflict could soon
become a thing of the past
the only remaining question is will we
see a solution to that core Palestinian
problem so I really hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos several
times a week also do not forget to check
out our friends at reconsider media they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also a big THANK YOU to
morning brew for sponsoring this video
please do check out their free
newsletter below this video and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]